what I want to do in this video is think
a little bit about the estate tax estate
tax and as the name of the tax implies
it is a tax on someone's estate or when
someone passes away is a tax on what
they want to leave behind to whoever
they want to leave it to either in their
will or in their family or whoever they
want to leave their stuff to and
sometimes it's referred to as an
inheritance tax inheritance tax and
sometimes you'll hear talk this way on
the news maybe it's a little bit
derisive it's called a death tax a death
tax and the general idea let's say that
right now my entire net worth I am worth
three million dollars I am worth three
million dollars and then I pass away so
this three million dollars goes into my
estate so this is my estate and so this
three million dollars could be all of my
savings could be my stock portfolio
could be the value of my land my real
estate everything I owned my car
everything combined is worth three
million dollars it goes into my estate
after I after I pass and let's say I
leave everything in my estate to my to
my daughter so I leave it to my daughter
it's at this point that the estate tax
comes into question of how much money
will my daughter get it turns out for
three million dollars my daughter is
exempt from a four for inheritance from
an individual the first five million
dollars are exempt so in the three in
this situation where I'm leaving three
million dollars for my daughter she
actually will get she actually will get
the entire three million dollars if
let's say I'm even richer than that
let's say that I have six million
dollars so let's say the scenario we
have six million dollars it all goes to
my estate it all goes into the estate
after my death and now the first five
million is exempt
so let me write my daughter over here so
my daughter will get the first five
million tax-free so five million
tax-free and then the the increment
above that exemption the increment above
what has been excluded will then be
taxed at a certain rate and that rate is
constantly changing but for the sake of
simplicity I'm going to go with 35% and
that's actually the rate in 2011 so the
rest of the 1 million the 1 million
taxed taxed at 35% so the federal
government will tax 35% of the 1 million
so they will essentially take 350,000
for themselves 350,000 for themselves
and my daughter will be left with 5
million and 650,000 right because of
this million you take up 350,000 you
have 650,000 left so my daughter in this
situation will be left with 5 million 5
million or maybe I could write five
point three five point six five million
dollars so the federal government took
350 thousand if I am super rich let's
say that I am worth let's say that I am
worth let me make a number to make the
math easy so I don't have to get a
calculator out let's say that I am worth
1 billion 1 billion 5 million dollars so
this is my net worth in this situation
the first 5 million will be excluded so
my daughter will get the 5 million will
get the 5 million directly that will be
excluded and then everything above that
will be taxed at the 35% so in this
situation you have 1 billion dollars
taxed 35% so 1 billion at 35 at 35
percent so in this scenario the federal
government the federal government will
take 350 million dollars would take 350
million dollars and so that would leave
of this billion 650 million left for my
daughter so in total she would get this
this 650 million plus the 5 million that
was excluded she would end up with a
total of 655
in dollars so I wouldn't feel too bad
for her she should be pretty okay so
that's just how the estate tax works and
the examples I gave with the five
million that is excluded this is for an
individual when they pass away if it's
being done as a couple this exemption is
actually 10 million so if between my
wife and I we have 1 billion 5 million
dollars and let's say I pass away and we
own everything collectively she actually
gets the extra-- joint exemption passed
on to her and then if and when she
passes away this would be 10 million
dollars that will be tax-free so in this
scenario if this is being done as a
couple my daughter would get the entire
six million dollars now the interesting
thing about the estate tax is it's
highly contested people always debate is
it wrong or is it right and I'll touch
on that a little bit I don't want to you
know I'll let you decide for yourself
but I'll give what I at least in what I
hear is the main arguments for or
against the estate tax so like like most
taxes there's always someone who will
believe that it is unfair so let me
write the let me write the for and
against for and against for and against
the estate tax so some people say it's
unfair look over the course of my life I
earned all this money I paid all of
these income taxes off of the money I
earned and now the stuff that I want to
leave behind to my children I am NOT I
am NOT able to leave it all to them you
know because you know because obviously
six hundred fifty five million is not
enough they deserve the entire 1 billion
five million dollars for being my child
and so there's this argument that it is
it is unfair or it's some kind of double
taxation the money was taxed the first
time it was earned and now it's being
taxed again once it's being inherited
the counter-argument to that is double
taxation is everywhere in our society
corporations pay taxes and then they
give dividends and the owners and the
stockholders pay taxes again and that's
kind of an exchange for having the
limited liability of the corporation you
pay taxes on your income and then with
that after-tax income you go buy
something at the store once again you
pay sales tax so double taxation
it happens everywhere the for argument
and somewhat the counter-argument
against the unfairness of it all is that
look we're exempting depending on how
you view it the first five or ten
million dollars so five to ten million
is exempt exempt so it's a little bit
the person who is for the estate tax
would say look it's a little
disingenuous when you make this
impression that your children are going
to suffer because they're not going
they're not going to be able to get your
house or they're not going to be able to
get your car they're going to be getting
they're going to be able to get all of
that as long as it's worth less than ten
million dollars which is not a small
amount of money and even above that
they're going to get sixty five percent
of everything so it's not like your
children are going to be left hungry
because of the estate tax and it's
actually a very small number of people
that the estate tax will even hit really
the rich because even the the
upper-middle class very few of them will
leave more than 10 million dollars
behind the other argument is if you're
going to tax anything so what to tax
what to tax do you tax income and
obviously you do have to tax income to
some degree to get enough revenue for
the federal government but isn't it
better to tax someone who did not work
for the money who's someone who's
getting the money I mean maybe they
already got every other privilege in
life they went to the best schools and
and all the rest and through connections
maybe good jobs why not tax the person
who is already lucky to some degree by
virtue of and this is just the the
argument someone would make and by the
way they're still going to get a lot of
that money it's not like they're going
to be left poor they're still going to
be fine and and to some degree maybe if
they have a little bit less it will be
more of an incentive for them to work
the other argument for the estate tax
and this is kind of a broader almost a
macro view of things of what might be
good for society is is if you don't have
an estate tax and we know that there's
these huge fortunes in the world where
someone creates a big business empire
and they have billions upon billions of
dollars and if someone has ten billion
dollars if someone has ten billion
dollars and let's say they don't have
that many they don't have that many
children that they leave it behind to
maybe they only have one child and they
leave that ten billion dollars to that
one child then that one child can litter
just let that income passively earn
interest they'll never have to work the
rest of their life and through the
passive earnings of of just the assets
being invested that over the course of
that child's life might grow to thirty
billion dollars it might it'll
definitely grow faster than the economy
itself and then that child if they have
no estate tax they'll pass the thirty
billion dollars to their children and
then that will grow and so what you
would have happening generation after
generation is this family if you say the
the the person who sets up the Empire
let's say this is the entire country's
GDP and right when the Empire sets up in
this person's life span this is their
proportion of the GDP and this is just
for simplicity but if you don't tax it
and this just passively over the course
of the next lifespan if there aren't
enough if there aren't enough offspring
to split to split up this fortune as the
GDP grows these people's investments
will grow even faster passively and so
over time this family will grow to own
more and more of the nation's wealth
without really having to do anything so
it almost creates this kind of nobility
class and obviously this that's what at
least many people in the United States
view is what's different about America
relative to old Europe to what used to
happen in terms of you know the French
Revolution and people just inheriting
land generation after generation and
never having to work and this right here
is a quote from Winston Churchill on his
on his view of an inheritance tax he
viewed it as a certain corrective
against the development against the
development of a race of the idle rich
so anyway that's the explanation of it
you can stand for for either side of it
but hopefully this at least gives you
the tools to think about whether you're
for or against it